notre série de portraits avoir 20 ans
dans les années 2020 aujourd'hui
rencontre avec un jeune youtuber
dijonnais il s'appelle paul jay z il
compte plus de 350 mille abonnés il
s'est confié à bon bagage et david segal
c'est dur c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20
en 2020 c'est dur
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle paul gay j'ai 20
ans j'habite à dijon et je suis youtuber
son bilan de paul jay z
[Musique]
ok les gars de retour des vacances donc
direct sachar bonne forme on tourne une
petite vidéo on est de retour dans la
chambre donc restez connectés ça arrive
bientôt sur youtube
youtube heures c'est faire des vidéos
les publier sur youtube puis bah quand
tu fais des vidéos et à des abonnés qui
te suivent du coup au quotidien qui
suivent cette vidéo c'est une petite
aventure plutôt sympa bonjour c'est paul
g l et je crois qu'en ce moment tout le
monde en a marre sur la chaîne youtube
j'ai trois cent cinquante mille abonnés
et je crois ma chaîne et totalise plus
de 20 millions de vues
moi en fait j'ai commencé les vidéos bas
très jeune j'avais 11 ans c'était en
2012 2013 je crois c'était à l'époque
des normales cyprien et mr lié tout ça
et puis bas depuis 2013 en gros oui je
fais ça aprilia 2e mec c'est celui qui
se la pète c'est qu'ils n'ont pas moi
tomber tu vas j'avais tourné la vidéo la
plus vue de ma chaîne c'est sur le maroc
je crois qu'il est bientôt à 3 millions
de vues
le maroc va explique l'entourage est
allé au maroc j'avais trouvé des vannes
et tout à faire en tournée c'est les
week-ends du coup avec mes potes donc
sur trois semaines je rendrai très sain
que des fous rires eh ouais je crois le
montage avait du coup qui fait pour une
fois faire le montage et wayne ans a été
la vidéo la plus vue lui verser les
premières gouttes du thé donc la brh
s'élève vers le ciel la lune tout en
restant droite voilà tout en gros dans
mes vidéos je parle de mon quotidien que
ce soit
l'école voilà les études le sport mais
mes voyages quand je pars à l'étranger
tout ça les filles moi ce que je kiffe
surtout c'est de jouer c'est assez dur
de faire le con
[Musique]
je suis en école de commerce à lille et
ça se passe plutôt bien je rentre en
deuxième année donc tout est bon entre
nous je sais pas trop encore ce que je
veux faire et puis dans cette dimension
commerce ça ça me plaisait et puis à
l'école dont j'avais des assez bonne
note et tout donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas tenter oui une école de
courir soit non
tu peux venir te plaît
aidez-moi que j'y pense est ce que je
ressens
en tant que maire je voulais qu'il y ait
le côté entre guillemets parachute pour
sa vie future professionnelle que si ça
marche pas aussi la nama lourd album
monsieur faire autre chose il est
toujours ce fameux diplôme d'école de
commerce qui fait qu'il peut aller et
peut faire ce qu'il veut de sa vie quoi
toutes espèces étaient différentes
espèces
apple avait potes à mes amis pour pour
tenir la caméra pour jouer dedans parce
que j'aime beaucoup plutôt que de payer
des figurants et cambrai c'est chaud la
recrudescence des cas du cofinancement
sa part dans toute la france c'est chaud
il faut pas le chauffer 1
donc on est depuis le début du collège
donc on a habitué à le voir faire ses
vidéos à l'aider à tourner et puis même
du coup d'y participer on est tous
contents d'eux pour l'aider à développer
tout ça
[Musique]
dans 20 ans
d'ailleurs a toujours pas de gaz après
paul cézanne jeu je sais pas j'espère
que j'espère qu'il sera toujours là
j'espère que je continuerai à faire des
vidéos 107 ans que ça me fait kiffer jeu
je continuerai à faire bon les gars
c'est tout pour moi vous en savez un peu
court sur comment je suis au quotidien
avec mes potes tout ça j'espère que ça
vous a plu sur ce rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro d'
avoir entendre dans les années 2020
merci france 3 pour la vitre c'était
beaucoup trop cool